que pensez-vous de cette élection est
provisoire sont les choses que vous auriez
aimé vous encourager à ce que
vous ayez votre propre entreprise et nous ne
travaillons pas pour quelqu'un cela ne vous effraiera pas
en vérité je pense qu'ils devraient se pencher sur
comment êtes-vous désolé si votre propre entreprise,
qu'est-ce que oui, elle travaillait pour
quelque chose que vous êtes déjà taxé, notre
entreprise, donc si vous continuez
à aimer quelqu'un, avez-vous l'impression d'avoir
eu une voix dans ce camping lors de cette
élection non euh comme personnellement maintenant  une
de mes choses est comme les frais de scolarité à l'université,
mais personnellement, je ne m'habitue pas à ce que mes
crimes puissent être comparés exactement parce que
vous ne pouvez pas parce que sur ce que j'ai
appris comme aller à l'école et tout ça, c'est
comme si j'étais comme des crimes  une tranche différente de
celle des bataillons de police et je
pense que nous devrions faire pour nous concentrer davantage,
comme essayer d'amener tous les Noirs à
s'entraider et rien dans un John,
alors avez-vous l'impression d'avoir eu une voix
lors de cette élection non parce que comme je
je regarde comme je suis wa  Pendant les débats, je
vois tout ce qui pourrait susciter tout un
tas de questions et bien que vous le sachiez en
particulier des jeunes et eux
pendant qu'ils se feront poser les questions,
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'aucun d'eux ne
réponde directement aux questions et à certains des
problèmes  est probablement Harvey comme l'argent
comme décider parce que l'argent comme pour la classe inférieure
pour être honnête, je ne pense pas que l'une ou l'autre des parties
ait jamais discuté et c'est comme le
bien-être des citoyens, je pense
qu'ils sont plus concentrés les uns sur les autres comme
nous le sommes mais  ce qu'ils prévoient de faire pour les
femmes et les emplois et les immigrants n'aiment pas
ça, vous savez, je veux dire que je suis votre
harceleur, mais je ne savais pas qu'ils essayaient d'
ostraciser et d'étiqueter comme vous le savez jugés
assez sans importance plus de problèmes il y a des
problèmes qui ne le sont pas  être abordé
comme quoi comme quels fonds il y a un
problème communautaire vous avez un problème de police
vous avez un problème de brutalité policière Je
pense que c'est la peur la seule fois où la police
me parle, c'est quand ils pensent que je fais
quelque chose de mal